[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24
emmanuel macron réélu président il a
emporté une nouvelle fois face à marine
le pen on va regarder ensemble les
résultats définitifs emmanuel macron qui
l'emportent avec 58 54 % des suffrages
exprimés
marine le pen vous le voyez battue mais
elle réalise le plus haut score de
l'extrême droite avec 41 46 % des
suffrages exprimés l'écart entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen reste
considérable messi s'est resserrée par
rapport au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 le taux
d'abstention a progressé il est de 28 %
le taux de participation est donc le
plus faible depuis
1969 emmanuel macron a évoqué une
nouvelle ère dans son discours alors
quels enseignements peut-on tirer du
scrutin qu'elles sont finalement les
enjeux des élections législatives ce
troisième tour comme l'appelle jean luc
mélenchon quels défis pour emmanuel
macron cinq ans de mieux at il dit mais
alors comment faut-il une nouvelle
méthode on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés mathieu
doiret directeur d'études d'ipsos
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue dans le
débat sur france 24 en face de vous il
ya 6000 à jafar bonsoir je suis la
présidente journalistes et présidente de
la ruche médias bienvenue à vous
également dans le débat anita auxerre
est avec nos bons soirs éditorialiste
politique à atlantico et claude weil
bonsoir claude weil chroniqueur
politique bien sûr et bienvenue
également dans le débat là on va d'abord
écouter bien sûr emmanuel macron et
marine le pen c'était hier soir juste
après les résultats de l'élection
ils conscience que ce vote mobilisent
pour les années à venir
je suis dépositaire
de leur sens du devoir
de leur attachement à la république
en dépit de deux semaines de méthodes
déloyales brutale et violente
similaires à celles que subissent au
quotidien les français les idées que
nous représentons arrive à des sommets
un soir de second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
avec plus de 43% des voix le résultat de
ce soir représente en lui même une
éclatante victoire
mathieu doiret alors les enseignements
c'est une défaite de le pen mais alain
score qui a progressé je le disais est
ce que la france est plus mouchetés si
je puis dire qu'en 2017 ou est-ce que
les clivages clivage territoriale qui va
sociales sont encore très prononcé les
clivages sont très très net quand on
regarde aussi bien la sociologie des
électorats que la carte même des
résultats donc la question la question
quand même qui est fondamental c'est est
ce que c'est 40 2% pour l'extrême-droite
ans et quant à la question que nous pose
les journalistes étrangers notamment la
réponse est c'est pas sûr et je pense
même pas sûr eh ben c'est pas sûr parce
que est-ce qu'on peut encore disent
considérer que tout l'électorat de
marine le pen se situe alexandre est la
réponse on l'a dans le sondage sénat en
vue d'accords sur le négatif de
même ne se positionne pas noble les
électeurs mais vous savez on leur
demande de se positionner sur une
échelle gauche-droite eux mêmes ne se
positionne pas à l'extrême droite est en
tout cas beaucoup moins volontiers par
exemple que ceux d'eric zemmour donc on
voit bien que aujourd'hui quand même ça
ressemble de plus en plus à ce qu'était
la gauche il ya 50 ans
parce qu'il ya 50 ans les diplômés votez
pas à gauche les cadres et votez pas à
gauche et les ouvriers y voter à gauche
donc la gauche plutôt communis bas c'est
ça alors donc ça a énormément changé
mais est ce que la france est singulière
en la matière il s'est passé un truc
incroyable en angleterre en 2019 quand
des circonscriptions qui avait toujours
voté travailliste depuis le suffrage
universel ont voté conservateur à cause
justement de la cette volonté d'aller
jusqu'au bout du vote qu'ils avaient
fait au référendum du bric citer deux
dates de voter pour le prix d'une liste
qui allait délivrer le bric c'est donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que oui un
réalignement on est dans une
dans une période de ré alignement en
fait il a commencé en 2017 ce
réalignement il a lu aux états unis
depuis déjà pas mal de temps il a eu
réalignement 3 et quoi eh ben ils nous
montrent que c'est un réalignement alors
ça s'appellera plus à gauche et la
droite si l'on veut mais enfin il y aura
quand même une bipolarité en réalité
cette division tripolaire elle est
probablement temporaire
entre 1958 et à 1972 par exemple on
n'appelait pas à la droite la droite on
l'appelait la majorité et puis après on
a fini par dire la gauche et la droite à
partir de 74 bon c'est peut-être très
temporaire tout ça on devrait pas
tout voir à travers le prisme de nos de
notre sémantique du passé donc mais ces
trois blocs en ont parlé claude weil ses
résultats ci correspond tout de même à
une fracture dont classe sociale et une
fracture territoriale permet clairement
le la sociologie des électorats le monde
la géographie aussi vous avez des quarts
derrière vous qui sont parfaitement
éloquente le sud a voté
majoritairement marine le pen et de
grands tester et des voeux ce qu'on
appelle les hôtes france deux régions
seulement a quand même enfin voilà et
l'ouest a voté l es le centre le centre
ouest ont voté massivement les manuels
de macron et surtout les métropoles ont
voté massivement menez emmanuel macron
parce que c'est une sociologie plus
tourné vers l'âme vers le la
mondialisation vers des verts le des
salariés du privé rectorat plaisance
électorale j'ai un électorat diplômés
enfin toutes les caractéristiques
sociologiques se croisent pour montrer
qu'on a deux électorats très très typé
alors après on peut discuter à perte de
vue ça va est ce qu est l électorat
d'extrême à deux mois je pense que
marine le pen qu'un d'extrême droite je
connais des gens qui votent pour elle
qui ne sont évidemment pas des gens
d'extrême droite il ya une composante ça
a été évoqué
l'ensemble des démocraties occidentales
et balayé depuis une dizaine d'années
par une vague appelez-la
national-populiste appelé la protesta
t'ai appelé d'anti système c'est en gros
la même chose avec des adaptations à la
culture l'une local et national mais ce
qui se passe avec urban en hongrie
ressemble beaucoup à ce qui s'est passé
avec le brésil en angleterre qui
ressemble beaucoup à l'élection de trump
contre madame clinton et qui ressemble
beaucoup au mouvement le pénis chez nous
et au mouvement salvini en italie et au
mouvement qui a été pionnier d'ailleurs
delà de l'extrême droite autrichienne
qui a été une des premières à accéder à
des fonctions officielles au
gouvernement donc donc là donc si on
parle de barrage je dirais que c'est pas
seulement madame le pen que mr emmanuel
macron a fait barrage emmanuel macron a
fait barrage à ce mouvement qui balaye
de l'ensemble du monde occidental et
ceux qui d'une certaine façon
relativise beaucoup le succès de marine
le pen moi je pense que l'élection
n'était pas plié d'avancé que rien
n'était joué était le si je peux me
permettre encore un commentaire à vendre
pas trop parler mais le j'étais quand
même totalement estomaqué par la soirée
avec doral dersoir
hier soir et appris que les poissons
volé et que les oiseaux nager et que le
psg gagnera rien ne peut arriver parler
de son éclatante victoire et l'ensemble
des commentateurs parler de la défaite
des manuels mère c'était qu'il s'était
littéralement surréaliste puisqu'on est
sur une télévision qui s'adresse à
l'étranger j'ai aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'amis étrangers au téléphone me dit
comment ça marche en france elle gagnon
qui perd les élections
en même temps accepter la défaite
contrairement à d'autres années c'est un
art de transformer les chèques en
victoire on sait ce qu'elle a fait 42%
personne ne les avait obtenus depuis la
nuit des temps quand vous dites que 42%
des français ne sont pas l'extrême
droite bien sûr mais c'est un vote de
rejet des les les électeurs de marine le
pen sont des électeurs qui n'ont pas
voulu d'emmanuel macro déclaré emmanuel
macron ce n'est pas la même victoire en
pourcentage il a amélioré son score par
rapport à 2017 mais il a perdu deux
millions doit donc c'était très
ambivalents cette élection et ce
résultat d'ailleurs lui-même ne s'est
pas montrée triomphale illacais ce qu'il
a dit dans son discours il a dit j'ai
bien compris que les gens qui ont voté
pour moi il ya une grande partie qui n'a
pas voulu de l'extrême droite et il
avait sans doute déjà vu le sondage sais
pas si c'est vous qui l'aviez réaliser
non je crois que c'est vos confrères
d'opinion way qui disent qui dit que 65%
des français ne veulent pas qu'il
obtienne une majorité envers lui
gentil totalement
juste juste encore un tout petit moins
les les deux petits sonore vous avez
passé était absolument fascinant parce
que on avait une déclaration de guerre
et une déclaration de paix et on avait
une déclaration de victoire de la
vaincue et un vainqueur
extraordinairement modeste qui remercier
non pas ses électeurs mais ceux qui
partent de voir avaient voté pour lui
alors qu'il ne l'aimait pas c'est une
situation très saine a fait non pas
qu'il n'avait pas fait en 2002 yasmina
jaffa un mot peut-être à tiébissou
retour sur ces fractures puisque pour
avancer un petit peu qu'on comprenne
bien justement pour ce public
international qui nous regardent
fracture classes sociales fracture
territoriale on le retrouve encore dans
scrutin n'ont en effet c'est vrai que le
fait que hier il ait eu une sobriété on
voit là derrière vous les images de
brigitte macron qui ne sourit pas il
n'arrive pas tout seul il a des enfants
avec lui parce que ce qui est très
important pour lui dans ce quinquennat
ça va être l'éducation ça passe aussi
par là la place des français la colère
qui est là je nuancerais un petit peu
les 42% qui ont voté non pas voter tout
contre emmanuel macron mais contre un
système contre mais cnpa emmanuel macron
ça fait longtemps que ça ne va pas les
deux ça fait longtemps que ça ne va pas
il représente quelque chose il est
d'ordre de la réussite il est arrivé en
2007 avec une histoire une idée et
prenez votre risque essayé la france qui
va bien nous allons tous être des
start-up heures tout va bien cette fois
ci raconte autre chose il parle du plein
d'emplois il vient avec des enfants il
dit que peut-être il faut remettre
l'école à au coeur du système parce que
ça passe par le diplôme parce que ça
passe par la place que l'on a parce que
ça passe par la légitimité que l'on a
par rapport à l'autre on est dans une
société où on se regarde tous beaucoup
où on voit la réussite des uns et des
autres à travers des réseaux sociaux et
où il ya une jalousie qui est là et qui
est prégnante par rapport à la réussite
et il représente ça c'est à dire qu'il
ya quelque chose de viscéral dans la
personnalité des manuels macron et c'est
pour ça qu'ils aient relax et du
ressentiment 13 av écrivait oui et c'est
ce qui c'est ce qu'il se passe c'est ce
qu'il se passerait s'ils n'ont pas
seulement bien sûr il ya une multi
factorielle la situation à laquelle nous
sommes est multifactorielle mais pas
pour parler de cette réussite et de
d'emmanuel macron qui est tenté un petit
peu de excusez moi d'avoir gagné c'est
un peu ça c'est qu'il est en train de
comprendre qu'il a un peu évolué en tout
cas pourvu que ça dure qu'il a évolué
sur la façon qu'il a s'adresser au
peuple pour but mathieu doiret ya un mot
sur les outre mers tout de même parce
que ça aussi ça beaucoup choqué un
raz-de-marée au départ pour plus tôt
jean luc mélenchon et puis tout d'un
coup un raz-de-marée pour marine le pen
je veux dire que peu de monde comprend
qu est ce qui se passe dans les autres
mers et une très forte abstention déjà
oui bon qu'une terre ce n'est pas
nouveau ce qui est vraiment nouveau
c'est de voter pour marine le pen donc
là c'est ça qu'il faut analyser d'eau
qu'est ce qui s'est passé d'abord
c'était récemment il y avait quand même
une situation sociale absolument
abominable on avait des émeutes
extrêmement violente ils ont tiré sur
les forces de l'ordre je rappelle la
situation économique est dramatique en
fait dans les antilles françaises
il est intégré et la guyane qui sont les
deux les deux seuls endroits en france
on peut parler d'invasion de
l'immigration clandestine par exemple
voyez donc j'ai à dire si ça n'a aucun
sens en métropole mais localement pour
le coup ça existe donc c'est pas du tout
comparable par exemple au vote à hénin
beaumont la seul point commun quand même
c'est que tous les départements les plus
pauvres sans voter éléments d'abandon
voilà c'est arrivé le fait tomber
département on est tous les départements
les plus pauvres en métropole le plus
pauvre c'est je crois les pyrénées
orientales bon voilà le pas de calais et
c'est à la haute saône haute marne ce
genre de département que les barisiens
ignore comme les new yorkais ignore la
virginie occidentale louise et bien sûr
les dom tom qui sont des départements
donc ils se sont hélas corse d'ailleurs
aussi qui est très pauvre et qu'ils se
sont rappelés à nous en votant tous
effectivement massivement le pen ce
n'est pas leur tradition politique et ça
confirme que ce n'est plus un vote
d'extrême droite de leur point de vue à
eux les électeurs qu'elle soit une
candidate d'extrême droite je veux bien
la crise sanitaire est passé les cas
votre compte de vue de mon grand âge je
vous dirais que les dom tom dans les
années 60 étaient les départements les
plus légitimistes oui on votait de
gaulle et comme un seul homme et femme
et depuis les choses ont basculé
aujourd'hui la culture protestataires et
traitant et ça a explosé avec la crise
du coc vide et la sphère du vaccin ou
les élites écoles et les partis
nationalistes et moi ce qui m'a frappé
dans l'histoire du vaccin c'est que
l'aigle et les notables locaux vous
comprenez la politique de paris où il
était plutôt preuve axe il n'osait même
plus le dire parce que sinon ils
pouvaient pas aller faire des courses
il n'ya plus les partis de gouvernement
par exemple était très fort à l'époque
où il était légitime liste de bréhal et
se faire élire à la réunion dans les
années 60 est là aujourd'hui il n'ya
plus aussi bien encore ce que dans tous
les départements d'outre-mer il n'y a
plus de d'élus qui soit et l'erp et s ur
m ils sont tous deux partis locaux
autonomistes alternatif
quelque chose
je voulais juste te dire un petit mois
c'est sentiment d'abandonner tout on
mange tous en ce moment et énormément de
sondage celui qui m'a le plus frappé
c'est un qui a été fait par notre ami
partant de vous montrer du doigt et qui
est absolument fascinante parce que le
le le le critère déterminant pour
expliquer le vote et il est très
intéressant parce qu'ils cumulent le
vécu et le ressenti lequel alors c est
ce que vous êtes vous est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de votre vie si vous êtes
satisfait d'autres vies de plus en plus
vous allez voter de plus en plus macro
si vous savez vous pensez vous avez une
vie excusez moi une vie de merde vous
allez voter ce balisage afin qu'ils
allaient voter idiot guéri et les
échelles comme disent les sondeurs sont
impressionnés c'est linéaire vanessa
silence % à 15 % c'est c'est
impressionnant alors cap sow
législatives un des 12 et 19 juin c'est
le troisième tour affirme jean luc
mélenchon on écoute
ne vous résignez pas au contraire
entrer dans l'action
franchement massivement la démocratie
peut nous donner de nouveau le moyen de
changer de cap
le troisième tour comment ce soir
les 12 et 19 juin ont lieu les élections
législatives
vous pouvez battre monsieur macron et
choisir un autre chemin 1 et à auxerre
alors là c'est le troisième tour
mélenchon espère devenir premier
ministre assez plausible
j'ai du mal à y croire en fait quand il
fourier
ce que vous avez
électoral c'est-à-dire les élections
législatives qui suivent de quelques
semaines l'élection présidentielle il y
a en principe un effet souffle comme on
appelle ça qui donne une majorité au
président qui vient d'être élu
ça a été massivement le cas en 2017 ça
avait été le cas en 2012 et en 2007 et
en 2002 après la réélection de jacques
chirac oui tout à fait alors dans le cas
de 2002 oui et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en 2002 j'ai pas le
souvenir que les socialistes aient dit
on va se venger
olivetti ville était complètement
abasourdi ils ont pas fait campagne eh
ben ça c'est pas si le venge pas encore
nous y menons mélenchon est déjà en
campagne ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en
2010 est par contre c'est tout a
commencé exactement pareil en 2007 c'est
pour ça que moi je n'ai pas le sentiment
que tout ce qui se passe maintenant à
nouveau oui parce que mélenchon tenait
exactement le même discours en 2017 et
par ailleurs en 2017 au premier tour il
ya eu l'effet de souffle légitimiste un
parti qui n'existaient pas six mois
avant a fait plus de 30 % et au deuxième
tour on a quand même vu des socialistes
ou des républicains se fait ravir par
les uns des républicains et les autres
des socialistes est tous des
mélenchonistes pour battre des
républicains manche qui était en tête
donc vous commencez curable aucun bloc
mélenchon à l'assemblée oui une
abstention et non ça ce mélenchon à la
crau lui fait défaut à l'assemblée
à la mi automne reb à gauche ce qui se
passe les gens ne les a soumis commence
à discuter avec les communistes qui
représente encore quelque chose dans
certains coins les valets que les hauts
placés là et maintenant les socialistes
donc ça veut dire si les insoumis prenne
le leadership de la gauche
aux législatives je dis pas qu'ils vont
gagner mais ça veut dire que c'est eux
qui vont dominer le bloc de gauche qui
sera élu au mois de juin et donc ça
n'est pas tant qu'enseignants c'est un
coup de bluff n'est pas possible
mélenchon a réussi un coup de neuf à
croire puisque i love avant l'élection
présidentielle
il dit ça ça compte pas se laisser
pousser pour nom l'important c'est
premier ministre je suis candidat au
poste de premier ministre et nice à
paris s'il ya ce ménage a faim il fait
absolument ce qu'il veut c'est même sur
la sémantique on reprend l'idée de
troisième tour moi je m'y refuse il y à
une séquence politique était la
présidentielle il y aura une autre
séquence politique qui sera législatives
et sont ces deux élections différentes
qui avait avec des sociologies
différentes et une abstention différente
parce que l'abstention sera forte et il
n'y a pas de raison que ça que ça change
ça être encore pire qu'en 2017 donc ils
l'utilisent des termes pour faire croire
que l'histoire continue et que peut-être
il y a une revanche une belle à avoir et
il ne sort pas du jeu terre qu'en
sortant le dise il a dit fait mieux on a
eu le sentiment comme marine le pen qui
prenaient leur retraite et puis
finalement les deux je ne prends pas du
tout ça en disant je suis là donc c'est
le changement de visage politique aussi
qui fatiguent les gens faudrait
peut-être une autre proposition en 2027
on peut pas s'amuser en permanence avec
dans le cul
la proposition de la part des vingt-sept
là on est en 2022 oui je pense quand
même qu'il ya une forme de troisième
tour pour ces législatives puisque c'est
des du parlement que procès de la vie
gouvernementale et la vie du pays or
deux il n'y a jamais de vente il ya deux
courants présidentielle c'est pour ça
que jamais oui habitations après l'idée
du troisième avec le quinquennat une
sémantique geste qui va y en avoir une
cette fois ci je veux dire ça paraît au
dessus 28 ans il a juste vous qui suivez
justement la gauche depuis très
longtemps est ce qu'il peut y avoir
effectivement une sorte de gauche réunis
autour de jean luc mélenchon qui
remporte en fait un gros gants grands
groupes à l'assemblée est ce que c'est
un scénario possible que jean luc
mélenchon devient le premier ministre
alors mêlant chance vous ce n'est qu'il
ait fait un meeting avec un hologramme
là il est né il est en train de faire un
discours holographique c'est à dire il a
inventé la présidentielle qui comptent
pas la candidature au poste de premier
ministre qui n'existe pas dans notre
constitution et il se projette déjà dans
sa victoire pour mettre en oeuvre un
programme que les français n'ont pas
approuvé je rappelle quand même qu'il a
fait 22% premier tour et donc ils se
placent dans cette position là hier soir
il s'est posé à la fois comme candidat
premier ministre mais en reste et comme
leaders de l'opposition henri teissier
une bataille qui est en jeu pour le
leadership de l'opposition entre lui et
marine le pen et peut-être même candidat
pour 2027 si je suis pas sûr qu'il est
assurée bien sûr qu'il prenne sa
retraite et il a réussi à imposer un
narratif absolument incroyable qui ait
ce truc que dans tout le monde a repris
sans réfléchir c'est le mal élu jamais
un président n'a été aussi mal élu
d'abord c'est faux
statistiquement c'est même année
vous savez le mieux élu de la 5ème
évidemment c'est chirac contre à 80 de
mon sens mais le deuxième mieux élu
c'est macron 2017 et le troisième mieux
élu c'est macron 2022 est alors dans
mélenchon est allé trouver ce truc au
fond d'un placard qui est calculé par
rapport aux inscrits souk aucun pays
démocratique n'a jamais fait on n'a
jamais calculé par avoir inscrit parce
que si on calculait par rapport aux
inscrits tous les miqo'tes député de la
france est soumise aux sons été élu
entre 15 et 20 % des inscrits mais ça y
est la devise cette règle ne s'applique
pas c'est pour cent c'est ce qu'on
disait d'après votre ipsos 56% des
français souhaitent une cohabitation est
alors non enfin tirs la réalité c'est
que très honnêtement j'étais quand même
assez la question
des prisonniers je suis désolé mais en
fait les perdants imposer leur
rhétorique et leur vision du monde et là
on est depuis là ça fait vingt-quatre
heures qu on devient tous on marche sur
la tête on vient on voit tous désormais
le monde à travers les yeux de ceux qui
ont perdu l'élection
ce que nous disent les gens ce qui est
logique c'est que ils ont pas
particulièrement envie que ceux qui ont
fait 28 % au premier tour et 80% des
sièges ça c'est le problème du mode de
scrutin mais la cohabitation des eaux
jamais dit qu'ils voulaient que jean luc
mélenchon non financières la réponse est
je ne veux pas que macro une majorité
ils ont jamais dit je veux que jean luc
mélenchon soit premier ministre parce
que quand même lui effectivement il fait
que 22 % 80 pour d'autres là on réécrit
l'histoire vraiment 80 % des français ne
souhaitait pas ce duel est malgré tout
sont élevées à exister donc bon là je
pense qu'il faut prendre les choses
alors après jean-luc mélenchon on va
parler tout de même d'eric zemmour du
bloc dont d'extrême droite alors il dit
viser haut
on va écouter on va ré écouter eric
zemmour ce qui l'a dit justement il ya
puis ensuite on va écouter j'ordonne
bardella jordan bardella qui est le
président du rassemblement national et
on peut dire qu'il a changé de discours
on va écouter un petit peu
hélas hélas hélas c'est la huitième fois
que la défaite frappe le nom de le pen
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années et ce n'est vraiment pas de
gaieté de coeur que je l'annonçais
il n'y a pas d'alliance deux parties à
proprement dit en revanche nous sommes
en train de constituer un grand pôle de
d'opposition à la politique d' emmanuel
macron un grand pôle qui n'en fermer ni
dans la droite ni dans la gauche qui est
un pôle
populaire sociale qui rassemble les
français à venir tous horizons qui nous
ont rejoints dans ce dans ce second tour
et donc on aura probablement vocation à
soutenir des gens qui ne sont pas issus
du rassemble un seul c'est tout ce que
je peux vous dire pour l'instant yasmine
haj apparaissent qui aura des alliances
à c'est à l'issu justement de la
première réunion à du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui manifestement il
avait mal perçu ce qu'a dit eric zemmour
hier mais lui repris date c'était
affaires s'est amélioré peut-être
finalement tout de même des
encouragements un rapprochement ou pas
je ne pense pas en tout cas l'idée pour
marine le pen et on voit bien à travers
le discours de jordan barre des lacets
de s'éloigner le plus possible des
réactions exagérées de eric zemmour donc
l'idée c'est ne pas de ne surtout pas
parler de rassemblement de l'histoire du
prénom de 2,2 grand remplacement par don
de ré immigration l'idée c'est surtout
de s'éloigner le plus loin possible pour
que comme l'a dit jordan bardella que ce
soit l'union de tous parler aux français
qui se sentent pas bien qu'il soit de
gauche ou de droite on repart dans les
thématiques du ni ni mais faire la
couleur du rassemblement national qui va
peut-être même lui aussi changé non
peut-être qu'il va s'appeler
rassemblement union et enlever le mot
nationale pour enlever cette idée que
d'abord le front national et le ratio
national sont des partis qui regarde la
france d'un point de vue couleurs et
n'ira c'est donc un parti d'extrême
droite mais annie laroche est ce qu'il y
aura des accords entre leur assemblée
nationale et le parti d'eric zemmour en
ce qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord formel
mais il y aura des accords locaux c'est
aucun candidat ne peut gagner une
circonscription puisque c'est une
circonstance un scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours aucun candidat ne peut gagner
si il est estampillé front national et
s'il a un concurrent et maurice temps
face de lui donc il faut qu'il ya des
candidatures uniques donc ça se fait par
accord tacite ou écrits mais sans que ce
soit proclamé qu'il y à un sommet et qu'
il ya une charte commune il y aura pas
en revanche
m marine le pen a pas profité du report
de voix d'eric zemmour donc il y aura
forcément
reports de voix d un vote d un pour le
pour les
les données d'un sondage c'est à dire
que c'est très intéressant et d'ailleurs
c'est pour la force est de constater que
pour une fois les électeurs sur la ligne
avec les personnes pour lesquelles il
vote parce que les électeurs de l'exome
moore sont très majoritairement en
faveur d'une alliance et les électeurs
de marine le pen beaucoup plus sceptique
ce qui est normal puisque l'électorat de
marine le pen a deux composantes
historiquement une qui comme l'une avec
zemmour est une qui n'a rien à voir
c'est ce qui est localement ce que vous
dites anita est très important c'est que
localement il va y avoir des endroits où
ils ont absolument besoin des légendes
et autres notamment en paca probablement
parce que là on est dans des terres
historiques pour plein de raisons mais à
hénin beaumont le candidat reconquête
ici en algérie est
très très heureux dans cette élection
qui ne ressemble à aucun aucune de ce
que celle qu'on a vécue depuis 50 ans
c'est que c'est unique c'est une
élection où il n'y aura pas de reset
d'habitude élections présidentielles
ouvre une nouvelle page c'est une page
blanche et balles neuves au tennis là ça
n'est pas du tout le cas on retrouve la
france le 25 avril exactement dans
l'état où on l'a laissé le 9 avril c'est
à dire avec des forces politiques
éparpillés et un premier tour qui a fait
qui a créé il ya eu trois primaires
macron à gagner la primaire des partis
de gouvernement le pen a gagné da par la
primaire des droites radicales et
mélenchon a gagné la primaire des
gauches donc on a théoriquement un
schéma tripolaire mais en réalité les
douze forces politiques éparpillés sont
elles existent et la question qui est
posée aujourd'hui aussi bien à la gauche
qu'à droite c'est la même c est ce
qu'ils sont capable de cristalliser de
30 de transformer de métaboliser en une
force politique organisée ce qui ce qui
s'est passé dans les urnes au premier
tour ça n'est pas du tout gagné parce
que d'après vous avez des intérêts
d'appareils vous avez d esprit de
boutique vous avez des détestations
lorsque faure premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste a dit on va négocier
avec eux avec
jean luc mélenchon un tiers de son
conseil national a dit non pas question
on va pas se laisser vassaliser par ces
extrémistes à la droite le plr est un
parti à la dérive qui n'a même pas été
capable rendez vous compte le grand
parti de 20 noms le parti du général de
gaulle qui a inventé la scène grimpe lui
n'a même pas été capable de prendre une
position claire sur le second tour
d'élection présidentielle
alors qu'après que leur candidate a fait
4 7 ou 8 je suis plus au premier ce que
ça veut dire à nouveau que les jeux ne
sont pas faits ça veut dire que comme
disait l'autre n'existe encore avec la
recomposition elle commence maintenant
et que d'une certaine façon ce sont les
électeurs qui m'ont a fait je paraisse
prenez l'exemple de l air l air et eau
est aux abonnés absents ça existe plus
mais les les français ont montré aux
élections locales qu'ils étaient
parfaitement capables de découpler leur
votre local du vote national on peut
très bien éliminer madame pécresse et
tenir à ça c'était déjà le cas avant que
lisa ses députés l air aux municipales
et aux régionales les vieux partis ps et
élèves ont fait des cartons et c'est
donc il n'a sans force donc en vrai la
thèse qui va s'opérer à l'air c'est que
chacun va se mettre à son compte chacun
va regarder dans sa circonscription
quelles sont les forces quelles sont les
adversaires quels sont les partenaires
avec qui on peut dîner et va faire sa
petite popote dans sa petite compte dans
un petit e dans sa petite gamelle et la
rue de vaugirard pardon pour nos
électeurs étrangers c'est le siège de
l'air la rue de vaugirard tout le monde
s'en fout paradoxe ultime sans que leur
victoire on pourrait dire aux élections
régionales aura été en fête aura demi le
dernier clou dans le cercueil de l air
et du ps puisque ils sont prisonniers
maintenant du fait que comme ils
tiennent les conseils régionaux ils ont
ils peuvent pas se plier enfin ils
peuvent pas se soumettre à mâcon parce
que dans ce cas là ils perdent cet
argument des territoires que sur lequel
its nar est déjà en train d'essayer de
reconstruire la plate forme et que en
même temps cet ancrage territorial les a
absolument pas empêché de faire des
scores lamentable y compris dans des
régions qu'ils contrôlent alors amour
peut être estimée à jafar comment va
gouverner parce qu'on va parler
justement du futur gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron comment peut-il
gouverner avec une assemblée qui sera
peut-être très dispersés sont peut-être
une vraie majorité ou peut-être il peut
encore obtenir la majorité ce qu'il va
obtenir la majorité que là on est à 24
heures
en effet vous avez très bien résumé d'un
mini traumatisme de renversement des
charges entre celui qui gagne qui
croient qu'il a perdu et avec une
attitude très différente pour celle qui
a perdu mais non je pense que vraiment
les français ne sont pas demain que si
jamais il ne donne pas la majorité au
président on ne pourra pas vérifier que
ce qui nous a proposé hier avec humilité
en huit minutes puisse se faire ça va
bloquer pays il voulait faire la réforme
constitutionnelle il ne l'a pas fait
parce que le sénat a bloqué cette fois
je pense qu'il va la faire parce qu'on
se rend bien compte que le ras-le-bol
est là c'est vraiment du point de vue du
système mais ça qu'il ya une majorité
année alors enfin gilles lamour avoue
penser mais surtout par une majorité
compte de réforme des institutions on
parle de réforme du mode du mode de
scrutin et ce ne sont pas les
institutions le mode de scrutin ou deux
il suffit simplement nouvelle fois le
mode de scrutin va l'avantager cette
fois encore a priori là il va le mode de
scrutin va l'avantager bien sûr mais ça
ne peut plus durer il faudrait
qu'on ne peut pas vous mais pour cette
fois à priori laurent une majorité mais
si aujourd'hui on va voter
on n'a pas encore voté
encore une fois le les ça fait quand
même plusieurs élections post
présidentielle en dépit de l'inversion
du calendrier comme akon des petites
surprises en 2007 elle s'est un peu fait
peur au deuxième tour la gauche faisait
50 % à cause de la tva sociale
mitterrand 88 et en 88 mitterrand n'a
pas eu de majorité pour le parti
socialiste et a prétendu qu'il avait
fait exprès c'est peu probable non il ya
un autre problème c'est
la question c'est que surtout attention
jeu j'entends beaucoup l'expression dose
de proportionnelle ça n'existe pas les
dozos passé il n'ya jamais il ya aucun
pays qu'à une dose vous avez soit c'est
tout au rien qu'en mer en fait c'est à
dire comme allemagne vous avez des
circonscriptions uninominales mais c'est
à la proportionnelle que les sièges sont
répartis à la fin donc ça pourrait être
un des chantiers
avec une
voie là mais pour revenir la question
que vous posez au foncier que va faire
macron de sa victoire s'il a une
majorité de ces nouveaux défis moi c'est
la grande intervenaient alors je ne sais
pas ce qu'il a dans la tête et je ne
suis pas sûr que lui même ce très au
clair avec ce qu'il a envie de feu alors
l'ex juge anti dit on va faire autrement
ça veut dire quoi est ce que ça veut
dire qui va s'orienter vers une
politique de pacte sur le mode belge ou
sur le mode germanique c'est à dire on
discute avec des chefs de partis et ont
créé quelque chose qui soit un programme
de gouvernement négocier ou est-ce qu'on
reste dans la logique vème république
pris dans la république voilà le
programme c'est ça vous signer en bas
vous pouvez disposer c'est ça inventer
un
[Musique]
nouveau parlement dans le cadre des
institutions de la vème république c'est
extrêmement si la paire et s'il le fait
c'est le fait si l'on fait ça sera un
vrai changement institutionnel alors
allons changer la constitution va
continuer ces discussions pourraient
juste qu'on écoute gabriel atallah le
porte parole du gouvernement qui est
justement have parler de cette méthode
faudrait aussi que
sur le fond on veut aller beaucoup plus
loin beaucoup plus fort sur un certain
nombre d'enjeux notamment la question du
pouvoir d'achat qui a été au coeur de
cette élection mais aussi l'enjeu
climatique on a entendu un message très
fort notamment de la jeunesse notamment
au premier tour autour de cette question
et puis les enjeux de sécurité bref de
protection des français es tu dans la
méthode ça veut dire qu'on veut oui
inventé une méthode nouvelle qui permet
d'associer beaucoup plus largement est
beaucoup plus directement les français
dans les décisions qui sont prises et et
à auxerre dont il parle bien d'une
nouvelle méthode là alors d'abord
emmanuel macron s'il veut avoir une
majorité il peut prendre un certain
nombre de mesures tout de suite il n'a
pas besoin de passer par le parlement
les maisons hormonal enfin suite non non
il peut l'écrire il ya un gouvernement
lula jour 2b dit c'est ça les
ordonnances mails
par exemple l'attribution d'un chèque
alimentation voilà il ya les mesures
pour le pour le carburant pour l'énergie
là ça va être un peu plus compliqué mais
il peut donner une impulsion pour avoir
cette majorité doucement quant à sa
méthode alors là excusez moi moi je le
forum permanent je ne vois pas quel
niveau il n'y en aurait un bon indice
c'est le choix du premier ministre oui
mais est-ce qu'il met ce qui maintient
pour expédier les affaires courantes
jean castex jusqu'aux législatives ce
qui veut dire aux français je vous
écouterai je prendrais l'assemblée que
vous enverrez ou est ce que il impose un
choix de premier ministre qui en soi or
insee aurait serait une signature en
bolivie tenant une signature politique
du second quinquennat c'est intéressant
il a fait ce sera difficile de garder
mathieu castex jusqu'au du statique
parce que finalement il ya quand même
deux mois de campagne et d'écrire et de
dire aux français nous allons écrire une
nouvelle page ensemble ça sera vraiment
un message contradictoire donc il doit
aujourd'hui dire ce qu'il avait dit à
marseille c'est à dire un premier
ministre vert avec poésie 20 premiers
ouvert deux mais oui souligné bert
est ouverte exactement on met un truc
c'est que dans la typologie de droite
dernièrement il a commencé très bon à
partie stella il envoie un message qui
va être un peu plus orléaniste et l'a
dit notamment parce que depuis que vous
aimez aller à lyon et se creuser en
verre mais non c'est pas ça dont je lui
ai parlé c'est que depuis que il est
très très il écoute beaucoup christian
estrosi a visiblement et nicolas sarkozy
qui porte en lui les traits bonapartiste
il a compris que ce qu'elle était quand
même son principal problème c'était les
élus locaux alors comme je viens de vous
dire les élus locaux se sont en fait
empêché de d'exister au niveau national
en privilégiant le local pendant
cinq ans donc aujourd'hui maintenant ils
sont bien dans les conseils régionaux
leur mairie mais ils ont plus aucune
chance d'être au gouvernement sinon en
passant ce pacte en fait avec l'état
donc je pense que c'est pas tellement
une question de couleur politique c'est
une question effectivement de parler aux
corps intermédiaires la cfdt on voit
laurent berger revenir énormément sur le
devant de la scène et parler au maire et
aux présidents de conseils régionaux à
muselier de tacles est ce qu'il va faire
du jacques chirac poste 2002 où est ce
qu'il va faire du gard schröder qui
pendant le dernier son dernier mandat à
réformer totalement les lois du travail
alors j'évite de faire des pronostics
effectivement ce qui va être un
réformateur ou est ce qu'il va être
plutôt immobile non mais immobile c'est
pas possible on a eu deux mandats
degrandi mobilité qui a été le second de
jacques chirac et le second de françois
mitterrand l'a oublié ni à mes amis qui
travaillait à l'elysée à l'époque était
très proche du président avait eu cette
formule heureuse donc dans le premier
septennat on a vidé le sac de ce qu'on
avait à faire et dans le second
mitterrand s'est contenté de surveiller
des nominations de garde champêtre et
c'est vrai que sur un second mandat
soit vous a pas fait le boulot soit vous
vous êtes heurter à de telles
difficultés que vous dise aura
manifestement macron n'a pas l'intention
de poser le sac
s'il a mis ce qui lui a probablement
coûté trois points dans les sondages
notamment dans la jeunesse et des
populations actives sida mis en tête de
sa candidature la 65 ans qui est la
mesure la plus impopulaire dans le monde
du travail c'est quand même qu'il a
l'intention d'en faire quelque chose
sinon l'avenir sinon ils auraient ils
auraient finasser de même de même la
réforme du ces du rsa les deux réformes
qu'il a mis sur la table c'est sa
candidature c'était de réformes
impopulaires et évidemment il le savait
parce qu'il est un peu moins bête que
moi donc s'il a fait ça c'est si la paix
seul oui mais le seigneur lectorat
pécresse elle est à l'époque l'était
déjà
vous pensez qu'il
je pense que connaissant connaissant
d'abord c'est un type qui adore la
castagne
il aime l'odeur de la poudre et du
serment il a comme chirac et
deuxièmement il a bien l'intention de
laisser quelque chose dans l'histoire et
pas seulement un type qui s'est coltiné
et gilet jaune et le peuvent ils être ce
qui était quand même pas de papa rien
donc et il a 44 ans donc ici il arrive à
faire ce qu'il a l'ambition de faire et
que beaucoup de français ne veulent pas
du tout c'est à dire en gros moderniser
le modèle social français pour l'adapter
aux contraintes de la mondialisation
pour le faire en trois mois s'ils
arrivent à faire ça il considérera qu'il
a rempli sa mission de jacques chirac il
n'a pas pu faire quand même pendant ses
cinq années à la présidence empêcher
donc il a il a eu envie de l'ambition on
se rappelle très bien aux loups de ce
qu'ils avaient des quand est ce qu'il
avait déclamé pour poids que la france
aille mieux et il à l'europe au coeur la
france au coeur et je pense que
clairement il a entendu la sonnette
d'alarmé et jordan bardet la raison si
tous les cinq ans un gars qui gagne 5
points la fois d'après et il aura cette
ressource est responsable il sait aussi
qu'elle a pris peau et à payer pour voir
que la france est incroyablement
éruptive mais que son service maps à la
longue la réfraction problème il sera
prêt pour bourg ils sont dans la rue
justement sur cette réforme possible des
réformes ah mais moi je crois qu'il n'y
a pas de réformes possibles sans
contrepartie et les montres mais la
contrepartie sociale elle se négocie il
ya au bout justement vous pensez qu'il a
parlé de jacques chirac ne sera pas
jacques chirac 2002 emmanuel magat
réformes négociées pandore il va pas il
va pas faire une loi en dix ans l'âge de
la retraite est porté à 65 ans points je
veux dire ça va être un long s'il a une
majorité un gouvernement etc ça sera un
processus et sansan au processus il ne
reculera pas à faire un tout petit peu
de vue quand même que il a beau être
très romanesque et opportuniste en
apparence il n'est pas aussi
machiavélique peut-être l'année au delà
des idées des lignes directrices et
notamment il est pas mal quand dans la
ligne de la l'école de toulouse le prix
nobel jean tirole et
les directeurs actuels de l'école alors
il ya deux
sont très importants mais christian
gollier qui a écrit à la fin du monde et
la fin du mois vous savez donc il va
avoir à gérer cette transition qui va
être quand même le un énorme chantier
pour les décennies à venir c'est à dire
qu' il va falloir que les gens acceptent
que la transition écologique a un coût
et le deuxième sujet c'est jacques
delpla qui est donc de l'école
d'économie de toulouse aussi qui dit
faut payer pour réformer donc qu'est-ce
que la lutte est serrée dit évident il a
expliqué il y aura des contreparties
c'est à dire que 65 ans de retard dont 1
c'est tout par exemple la retraite à
1100 euros voilà ce qui est fondamental
aussi ce qu on leur reprocher c'est un
casting plus plus compétents et moins
amateur et moi copinage de la première
heure voilà on est plus à la première
ronde et cinq ans après donc il faut que
dans son gouvernement y aider des
endroits égaler les en droit régalien
que c'est important mais la culture
c'est important qu'il faut quand même un
ministre de la culture qui se tiennent
parce qu'on en parlait l'éducation
nationale aussi parce qu'on en parlait
tout à l'heure c'était d'être entendu
bien sûr la santé aussi mais ça passe
par là d'être entendu des français c'est
d'avoir des gens compétents il nous
reste cinq minutes on va écouter tout de
même la réaction de brighton
je pense que c'est très important que
nous ayons à paris un président français
sur qui on peut compter quand il s'agit
des enjeux internationaux les plus
importants du symbole vie et en
particulier il à vis de la situation en
ukraine
savoir boris johnson bruxelles
la presse internationale ce qui est
votre métier tout à parle l'anglais et
tous les pays ont félicité macro et dans
toutes les chansons près la lumière
poutine en tout les y compris va dire
tout respecté on a le droit d'avoir un
double langage dans la vie mais tout
donne en europe en tout cas tout le
monde était enchanté dalé thomas crown
le vrai défi pour pour moi de son second
pilote c'est à dire paradoxal ces deux
des macros knees et l'exercice du
pouvoir c'est pas sympa pas là du du
syndrome de jupiter je parle d'autre
chose c'est que dans son premier mandat
la vie politique française a été
totalement focalisés dévoré par la
relation personnelle à macron les partis
politiques l'opinion
il ya eu une focalisation sur ce
président qui a pris des dimensions
dimension qu'avait commencé avec sarkozy
mais là ça atteint un haut niveau
personnification de la personnification
de la notamment des haines qui ont pris
des ddd pathologique mais aussi d
adoration et c'est tout tournait autour
de sa personne les partis politiques ont
arrêté de bosser le parti socialiste
était à la rue lr ne pressait pape avait
plus personne bosser on se contentait
c'est à cause d'eux bien sûr parce que
tout le rapport à macron dévorer tout le
tout l'espace politique japon de hausser
de pendu dans le second mandat il
faudrait si c'est si ça lui est possible
qu'ils prennent un petit peu de retrait
de façon à laisser respirer la
république mais s'il est consommé mettez
vous au boulot les enfants et faites-moi
des propositions je dirais sagna auteur
auteurs cercil et justement les partis
ne se recompose pas comment est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir véritablement ces corps
intermédiaires avec emmanuel macron va
rester dans leur famille terrienne les
corps intermédiaires ce sont des élus ce
sont des syndicats enfin ce sont les les
élus régionaux c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas
vraiment dialoguer avec eux mais le
problème fâche pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce que vous dites c'est la macro
nisation houle c'était justement la
jupette jupiter isation du pouvoir
prolonger parce qu'il y avait le
précédent landes de désacralisation qu
est ce qui a rendu le système fou c'est
simple c'est que il ya plus d'espacé
pour la droite de gouvernement puisque
la droite de gouvernement elle est au
gouvernement il ya plus d espace pour la
gauche de gouvernement puisque la cause
des mouvements elle est au gouvernement
du coup il ya une fuite aux extrêmes si
la vidéo
mr et le ps est il ya eu une fuite aux
extrêmes sur cette base là est ce que
quelqu'un peut reconstituer une offre
politique crédible et pas une offre
radicale qui sera pire revenir aux
anciens partis inventé une offre
nouvelle qui soit qu'est-ce qu'ils
soient qu'ils savaient ce qu'ils soient
gagnable passe complètement il sait que
sûr que les que l'extrémisme a très peu
de chances de remporter des élections en
france justement moi je voudrais juste
dire parce que en voyant jones a je me
dis qu'ils se ressemblent plus qu'on le
dit programmatique bien sûr en réalité
ils ont d'abord ils ont pris à
contre-pied le parti dont il était issu
ils ont discuté complètement la vie
politique ils ont fait des choses
incroyables comme on pensait pas
possible en réalité sont complètement en
phase avec leur époque et en réalité il
est pas plus dans le système que marine
le pen il a complètement démoli système
sciemment est en réalité c'est
simplement qu'on est en plein dans la
révolution et que quand il ya une
révolution pas tout le monde a le
sentiment de perdre avant de gagner
et c'est vrai qu'il y à aussi la
personnalité là où je rejoins ce que
vous dites claude c par rapport à la
personnalité il ya eu aussi toute cette
période pendant un an ou deux de petites
phrases peut-être l'apl premier message
pas très sympa voilà donc il ya eu tout
ça qui a fait qu'on a on a regardé
emmanuel macron comme une personnalité
presque de télévision ou de séries
d'ailleurs ça continue parce qu'il a
fait des petites séries comme des séries
netflix pour sa campagne et ça marche
pas très bien avec le slogan avec vous
qui veut pas dire grand chose on sait
pas ce que ça veut dire donc il faut
qu'il trouve une nouvelle sémantique une
nouvelle façon d'arriver je trouve que
lire la façon d'y l'arrière ça raconte
quelque chose on est dans un début de
récit c'est quand même plus intéressant
que le louvre donc voilà doxa qui
commence à raconter quelque chose donc
il faudrait continuer là-dessus et
sortir de la personne emmanuel pour être
densifié macron s'est inspiré des
conclusions mais d'affaires que là on
est trop dans la communication est l'un
des grands reproches l'époque très rares
à emmanuel macron c'est de ne pas avoir
structuré de force politique ils avaient
ou pouvaient le faire il a il a aspiré
une partie de la droite une partie de la
gauche il fallait qu'il structure un
véritable centre il n'a pas plié un truc
qui est drôle dans cette danse erika
était plus relevé dans cette image cki
bon il fait venir des petits des petits
des écoles c'est bien nous ait remarqué
qu'ils sont pas du tout en d'immenses
que mangeront disait que j'étais gosse
ils sont ils sont ils sont maintenus
comme comme pour aller à l'école en jean
en sweat shirt etc c'est assez marrant
en effet de deux ans tous les jours quoi
ils sont amis
dimanche est y avait plusieurs fois y
avait aussi peut-être le fait de venir
avec le tee shirt comme pendant les
meetings ils venaient tous le rejoindre
et c'est bien qu'ils aient pas le
t-shirt celle là ça aurait fait du
marketing après je crois qu'on ne change
pas c'est à dire qu'il va finir son
travail de démolition et que le travail
de reconstruction de l'offre politique à
lui les rats au bout de son programme je
pense mais la reconstruction des partis
politiques m c'est edouard philippe et
qu'on puisse les
journaux nuit-là il a rêvé on n'a plus
le temps
merci à tous les quatre
nages a faim merci a mis ko soeur et
merci à vous tous vous alors si vous
restez sur france 24
[Musique]